michel serrault bonsoir bonsoir nous
seuls sein de l'académie française
aurais-je dû dire et vous en plus d'être
réellement immortel vous avez 88 ans
michel oui
vous êtes l'homme de 88 ans le plus
jeune du monde finalement
c'est ce qu'on dit mais je cache ou bien
mon jeu oui c'est à dire oui je classe
en blog est trop jeune mais mais ce
n'est pas vraiment d'accord peinture
donc je me dis à se créer c'est pas vrai
heureusement vous est immortel parce que
à l'académie on trouve personne pour
remplacer les disparus y prendriez kivu
luc ferry par exemple il s'est présenté
il n'a pas été élues et élus à voter
pour ou contre
les votes sont secret mon cher alors
alors sinon c'est bis ou noir oui ciel
houellebecq par exemple penser qu'il
mérite de l académie française
j'aimerais bien qu'il vienne oui oui
d'accord très bien emmanuel carrère
d'encausse oui non y'a déjà sa mère qui
est là et voilà ce qui est secrétaire
perpétuelle problèmes de famille avec
arras en aimant pour les gens rentrent
pas me les affaires de famille est vrai
qu est ce qu est ce que vous savez qui
est frédéric beigbeder par exemple oui
bien sûr est ce que vous pensez qu'il
pourrait peut-être un jour entrer à
laquelle microsoft oui tout le monde
peut rentrer le cubain y compris vous
mon cher
sinon il reste il reste line renaud dont
line renaud ecalle mais bon ça c'est pas
gagné oui voilà un robot est ce qu'un
jour on pensait qu'il y aura robot avec
la ligue française mais du geste manière
je me tous des robots et et vous savez
donc par exemple comment maquiller ouais
on m'a mis des choses il faut l'écouter
je suis déjà un peu continent voilà et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu